what did you think about tonight
Taylor's performance artist of the
decade amazing everything was incredible
what an amazing show it was incredible
to hear her do all those hits we were
singing along front row I was amazing
and it was amazing music for all these
artists we got to experience that and
it's amazing for us yeah we're fans of
music to be able to be here and we're
with a bunch of our friends to be able
to watch to get a ticket to this show is
a huge deal for us so it was amazing all
right before I talk about Grammys and
AMAs and all that I do want to ask you
were you disappointed that shamila did
not kiss on stage tonight during senior
oh man I was waiting for it I was was an
amazing performance though shining for a
smooch it's all good it's all good Sean
he's like a little intimidating he's
just so good-looking his hair is always
perfect we just got off tour Bashan he's
a good friend of ours yeah a good time
such a great guy right yes I just want
to go to my notes here cuz I don't want
to mess this up because this week has
been incredible last two weeks okay
three AMA nominations and a win for a
CMA win and then two Grammy nominations
dan + Shay by the numbers is oh it's
insane man we came here we did not know
what to expect to be here amongst all
these superstars we got to AMA tonight
we got to not nothing I'm not counting
here correct you should be counting but
you know we got to so I'm excited about
that I'm very excited about it so it's
been amazing man we're so thankful to
all of our fans this being a fan voted
award is a huge deal to us I mean that
that is the real people who matter that
just those the people we make music for
so so you let's win an award at the AMAs
is just it's crazy to win - I'm gonna
pinch myself moment all those is there
any time to slow down cuz baby's coming
oh I never stop I never stops 24 hours a
day it's crazy
I've gone senile are you gonna be ready
for what I'm having a baby but we are
not I don't know if we're quite ready
for next year this is we got a huge
arena tour that we're going on next year
and I think I have I think in February
is whenever my wife is due and then take
the whole month off or you took one day
oh we only get like I think a few days I
think our first like Nashville show is
March 6th and 7th we're doing two nights
at Bridgestone Arena and it's like a
week after my second baby is where and
so it's gonna be nonstop but we're
excited man we're so pumped to have
those new music ups awesome now
thing post Malone was here post II he
sat through the whole show I know that I
need a collaboration I need the three of
you together I need you both to get a
face tattoo right away are you working
on I would get a face that too if it got
us a collaboration with post Malone
putting it out there he's gonna be like
yeah I'll do it I'm gay I don't know
he's way cooler than we are been able to
come back because I've been working on
this for a long time on Entertainment
Tonight he is he's like the nicest guy
ever we got to give him an award tonight
we hung out with him a little bit after
we've hung out with him a couple times
and he's an amazing guy got a lot of
mutual friends so I think it might come
in one of these days okay my lap real
last question I've been sitting here
dreaming up things for you to do this
year other than birth babies um okay
dan + Shay + the Jonas Brothers is 5 so
it's like and sync but it's better
except we're not good dancers those guys
could probably dance we got nothing but
it would be a mess five great guys in
suits out of sync coming 20 20
[Music]